President Trump gets into hot water over
a call with a soldier's Widow plus we're
gonna talk about him at the Heritage
Foundation and some actual big news that
people aren't talking about like the
biggest news of the year that people
aren't talking about I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
so the theme of today's show is that the
culture wars are obviously more
important to Americans than actual news
because there's some actual huge news
today in fact there are three pieces of
actual very very large news today and
I'm going to talk about all three of
those in just a second but first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
tracker comm the tracker comm so as I
have said before I lose things all the
time all the time in fact while we were
in Hawaii for vacation my wife lost her
phone we could not find it anywhere
anywhere and that is when she did the
thing that she has been taught to do she
grabbed her keychain and on it she had
her tracker device and she hit the
button on her tracker device and her
phone started ringing it had been buried
under the bed by one of my children the
tracker calm that's what it does for you
you're never gonna have to lose your
wallet phone keys again instead instead
you have this coin size device that fits
right on your wall in your wallet or on
your keys and then on your phone when
you install a program and what's cool
about this program is that when you
actually lose your phone even if you
left the ringer off right you're trying
to call it figure out where it is but
the ringers off the program that is
installed via the tracker means that
when you hit the button the phone rings
anyway so you don't have to worry about
that anymore either
it makes your life enormous ly easier
it's one of those problems you don't
really think about until it bites you in
the butt like every other day that's why
the tracker comm exists with tracker
pixel you'll never have to worry about
this again it is the lightest Bluetooth
tracking device on the market and again
you can put it on whatever you tend to
lose and you will never lose it again
tracker has a 30-day money-back
guarantee which means you really have
nothing to lose you can even locate your
item if it's miles away because every
tracker user is part of the largest
crowd locate network in the world so
it's like Waze except for finding your
things go to the tracker comm slash Ben
that's the tracker comm slash Ben to get
20% off any order that the tracker comm
slash Ben for 20% off any order one of
these things will make your life a lot
easier the tracker comm slash Ben and
again you get 20% off your order okay so
everybody wants to talk today about
President Trump making this phone call
to this Widow and why this is a huge
news story and whether President Trump
has no sympathy for widows of war heroes
and all of that and we'll get to that in
just a second but I'd like to suggest
that one of the reasons the media are
folk
hang on that is because there are three
very big stories that came out back to
back to back yesterday all of them good
for Trump all of them very bad for the
left the first story is the story with
regard to Isis so we now know that
us-backed forces have now taken Raqqa
okay Raqqa is Isis's last urban
stronghold it is it was the place that
was the headquarters for Isis in Syria
and us-backed forces say they have now
taken it and they've cleared the entire
place and basically Isis has been
restricted to this small portion of area
in the Euphrates River Valley one of the
things that you should know about Isis
and we played there their propaganda
videos in the past is that one of the
ways that they have drawn such a
traction to to so many people is by
claiming they have a broad territorial
holdings so if you actually look back at
the ISIS propaganda videos they would
say things like we have territory that
is greater than all of the United
Kingdom a UK is pretty small country but
still they would claim that their
territorial holdings were justification
they show that Allah was on their side
well now their territory has basically
been shrunk to the size of a dime and
that is thanks to the bravery of
America's troops and American allies
this is not all President Trump
some of this is President Obama a lot of
these operations were started under
President Obama President Trump did free
up the military to use different rules
of engagement which certainly helped he
took the shackles off the military that
existed Isis was in retreat before Obama
took office that has only accelerated
under President Trump according to the
New York Times right I'm sure on page
824 American backed forces said on
Tuesday that they had seized the
northern Syrian city of Raqqa from the
Islamic state a major blow to the
militant group which had long used the
city as a de facto capital of its
self-declared caliphate celebrations
erupted in Raqqa where residents had
lived under the repressive rule of
militants who beheaded people for
offenses as minor as smoking fighters
could be seen cheering and firing
celebratory gunfire in the streets
according to residents reached by phone
and text message u.s. CENTCOM stopped
short of declaring victory saying more
than 90 percent of Raqqa was an SDF
control that be the Syrian democratic
forces as an american-backed militia
made up of Kurds and Arabs
Colonel Ryan Dillon spokesman for the US
military and Baghdad said Tuesday Raqqa
was on the verge of being liberated said
there were still pockets of the city
controlled by Isis but Isis is
absolutely in retreat and now basically
Isis is a clean up Opera
at its height in 2014 Isis controlled
both mosul and raqqa
and now they control neither of them and
that is the testament again to the
bravery of American of America's armed
forces as well as our allies and his
tribute to the Trump administration I
guarantee you that if Barack Obama had
been in office when all of this happened
this would be front-page news and every
paper in the United States because it is
a major thing it is a major thing okay
it's it's pretty incredible what we were
able to do in a pretty short period of
time here since Isis really gained
prominence and credibility in 2013 2014
so good for American troops that is big
story number one big story number two
yesterday the FBI posted a document
revealing the James Comey former FBI
director had drafted a letter in July
2016 not recommending charges against
Hillary Clinton okay as you know as you
know that was way before he was supposed
to interview Hillary Clinton that was
way before he had all the information
and so this demonstrates that the fix
was basically in here the James Comey
knew that he wasn't going to indict
Hillary Clinton and who's drafting
documents to that event to that effect
literally weeks and months before he
bothered to do all the rest of his
research FBI officials according to the
hill FBI official James rye Becky in
mid-may requested an unclassified email
that officials quote sends any comments
on this statement so may we may roll it
into a master dock for discussion with
the director at a future date two months
later Comey would make his announcement
criticizing Clinton but that was two
months after he had already written his
ruling in the case demonstrating once
again that something deeply corrupt was
going on here
James Comey has a lot of questions he's
going to need to answer on that
particular matter so that is Story
number two and that one again does not
help be the left wing does not help the
Democratic Party and it doesn't help the
media which you proclaimed from the
beginning that Hillary was innocent
innocent innocent innocent okay story
number three this one is the most
stunning story it really is quite
amazing okay the story is basically that
you remember there was this story that
that Trump kept bringing up on the
campaign trail it was a rip from Peter
Schweitzer the guy who wrote Clinton
cash very very good researcher he has
his own nonprofit based down in Florida
in which he
investigates it's basically an
investigative journalism Center but
schweitzer had uncovered this story
about how rasa tahn which was the
russian nuclear agency had gained
control of one-fifth of america's
uranium supply and they had also given
massive donations to the Clinton
Foundation and it was cleared by the
State Department when Hillary Clinton
was Secretary of State and president
Trump used to talk about this on the
campaign trail all the time Hillary
Clinton denied there was any wrongdoing
she said that the State Department that
part of the State Department was not
under her charge she never knew about it
and all the rest and there were claims
that the Russians never did anything
illegal anyway so who cares right
nothing illegal was being done or at
least if it was being done nobody had
any knowledge well that turns out to be
a lie so according to the New York Post
today the Obama administration knew
Russia had used bribery kickbacks and
extortion to get a stake in the u.s.
atomic energy industry but cut deals
giving Moscow control of a large chunk
of the u.s. uranium supply anyway
according to report on Tuesday this from
the hill the FBI used a confidential US
witness working inside the Russian
nuclear industry to gather records make
secret recordings and intercept emails
as early as 2009 that showed the Kremlin
had compromised an American uranium
trucking company executives at the
company transport logistics
international kicked back about two
million dollars to the Russians in
exchange for lucrative no big contracts
a scheme that violated the Foreign
Corrupt Practices Act the feds also
learned that Russian nuclear officials
had gotten millions of dollars into the
u.s. designed to benefit the Clinton
Foundation at the same time then
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton
served on a government committee that
signed off on the deal sources told the
hill the racketeering operation was
conducted quote with the consent of
higher-level officials in Russia who
shared the proceeds from the kickbacks
an agent later stated in an affidavit
the DOJ under Attorney General Eric
Holder did not bring charges in the case
prior to the deals being cut at the time
Obama and the Clinton State Department
were trying to quote-unquote reset
relations between the two nuclear rivals
the first deal was wrapped up in October
2010 when the State Department and the
Committee on Foreign Investment agreed
to sell part of uranium 1 a
toronto-based mining giant with
operations in Wyoming Australia Canada
Kazakhstan South Africa and elsewhere to
rasa tahn which is the Russian nuclear
company giving Russia control over about
20% of the American
and supply okay her spokesman said that
she was not involved Hillary spokesman
said she was not involved in this and of
course the Obama administration said
there was nothing wrong with the deal
anyway except of course for how there
was something wrong with the deal and
the Obama administration knew it so now
here's what we know about the Obama DOJ
we always knew that Eric Holder was
corrupt we always knew the Obama DOJ was
corrupt but now we know that Loretta
Lynch at the DOJ had no intention of
inciting Hillary Clinton for miss B
misuse of classified material that we
know that now we know her predecessor
Eric Holder was basically signing off on
deals that were designed to benefit the
Clinton Foundation at the same time that
the DOJ knew that Russia was attempting
to wield influence in a corrupt man or
violating the law in the United States
pretty amazing stuff and pretty
devastating stuff if you're a Democrat
which is why Democrats today should be
thankful that that's not the headline
one of the reasons that's not the
headline of course is because the media
don't want these to be the headlines
they don't want Isis's defeat and Rock
got to be the headline they don't want
James commies memo to be the headline
they don't want the FBI knowing that the
Russians were attempting to corruption
being the headline they don't want any
of this to be the headline what they
want to be the headline is that Trump is
a bad guy and fortunately for them
President Trump has a bad habit of
opening his mouth at the wrong time
right the news cycle for him is actually
pretty good this week but he made the
mistake on Monday giving a press
conference in which as I talked about
yesterday
he has a tendency to go out over his
skis and the President of the United
States came out and he said that he
likes to call all the soldiers and then
he suggested not only that he liked to
call all the soldiers but that prior
presidents like President Obama and
President Bush did not like to call all
the soldiers I want to tell you about
this controversy and where I think it
stands and what actually is going on
here because I think it's overblown at
least based on the evidence we've seen
so far but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at my Patriot
supply so when you were a kid did you
are a helmet before you started riding a
bike correct well when disaster strikes
you need a food supply in your house the
fact is natural disasters happen the
fact is terrorist attacks happen the
fact is there may be some time in the
future when you are going to have to
break into whatever food you got in your
house and if you don't happen to have
much in your house you could be screwed
because the grocery stores could be
empty
you could not have access to them the
government may not be able to get to you
so at least for 72 hours you need to be
able to feed yourself and your family
that's why you need to visit my friends
over at my Patriot supply right now they
are selling a 72 hour emergency food kit
for just $17 and 76 cents that's 17
dollars and 76 cents that includes free
shipping by the way you can order now at
eight eight eight eight oh three 14 13
or online at prepare with been calm it's
prepare with been calm again it's $17 76
cents for 72 hour emergency food kit
you're prepared for any emergency with
that special low price there is a limit
for per order for per order they
believed in old-fashioned values and
they believed in you keeping your family
safe so go over to prepare with Ben comm
it's prepare with Ben calm 888 803 1413
order it now stick in your closet forget
about it until you need it you'll be a
lot safer for it again for just $17 and
76 cents get their 72-hour emergency
food kit at 888 803 1413 or prepare with
Ben calm okay so the controversy began a
couple of days ago when President Trump
again always a guy who who has a
tendency to speak out of turn suggested
that prior presidents had not done
enough to reach out to the families of
slain troops here is what Trump had to
say at a press conference a couple of
days ago the traditional way if you look
at President Obama and other presidents
most of them didn't make also a lot of
them didn't make calls I like to call
when it's appropriate when I think I'm
able to do it okay so he says he likes
to call him when he's able to do it but
other presidents haven't always called
and this of course drove a huge
firestorm because the suggestion seemed
to be the Trump was saying he is better
at calling the families of slain
soldiers than other presidents have been
which is not true there is no evidence
to this effect this created a huge
controversy as I said yesterday the
response of the media was not Trump is
saying evidence list things the response
of the media was Trump doesn't care
about the soldiers himself right the
media couldn't just restrict themselves
to the narrative that Trump was speaking
off the top of his head again and saying
terrible things again instead they had
to go to Trump is the one who really
doesn't care about the troops and then
conveniently conveniently from President
Trump the reason he was talking about
this is because he was he asked about
some so
were killed in Niger during one of his
missions and he hadn't tweeted in 12
days about it and had apparently not
called these people yet but he was going
to call them so all this happens and
then he calls the family of one of the
of one of the slain soldiers this the
slain soldier was Sergeant David
Tomlinson Yvette Johnson sorry and LU
David Johnson was killed in niger two
weeks ago and he leaves behind wife two
children his wife is pregnant with their
third and they married for a long time
obviously a very handsome young hero of
the country clearly and and so Trump
then called up the widow so yesterday
Trump calls up the widow and according
to the not according to the widow
according to a congresswoman in
fredericka Wilson
Trump was very rude to her he was just
terrible to her here's fredericka Wilson
talking about this is very convenient
the narrative right so the narrative was
Trump said that other people didn't care
enough about the troops the media said
Trump doesn't care about enough about
the troops and within 48 hours we have a
national controversy over whether Trump
was cruel to a widow right kind of
convenient how all that worked out so
here is here is Frederica Wilson making
that claim you know he knew what he was
signing up for yeah you say that
you know something to me that is
something that you can say in a
conversation but you shouldn't say that
to a grieving widow and everyone knows
when you go to war you could possibly
not come back alive but you don't remind
the grieving widow they're so
insensitive he should not have said that
and he shouldn't have said it okay so
here is the so Trump responds to all of
this by saying Democratic congresswoman
totally fabricated what I said to the
wife of a soldier who died in action and
I have proof sad exclamation point so it
is now some hours later he tweeted that
about five hours ago he has yet to
provide the proof that he talked about I
hope that he will because here is the
reality okay if Trump called up this
grieving widow and all he said was I
guess he knew what he signed up for
that's pretty terrible okay we have to
acknowledge that that is pretty terrible
there are two ways to read the comment
however and here is where the vagueness
gets me okay there are two ways to read
that comment if you call up the family
of a slain police officer firefighter
soldier and you say to them well you
know they died I guess yeah I know what
they signed up for it's pretty heartless
first of all number one most soldiers
don't go into battle thinking they're
going to die okay the the ratio is
someone on Twitter was saying this and I
think this is correct
the ratio of American soldiers who
served in Iraq versus American soldiers
who died in Iraq is one to five thousand
so that means that mostly the vast vast
vast vast majority of soldiers who serve
of servicemembers who serve are not
expecting to die in the line of fire
they know there's that possibility but
it's not like they're signing up to die
and they're certainly not signing up
even to experience the the tremendous
risk of death the same is true for cops
the same is true for firefighters so to
suggest this is what they signed up for
is is really pretty callous what they
signed up for is to defend the country
not to die if they have to die they will
but that is not the idea right the idea
is they're signing up to defend the
country I think that virtually all
soldiers that I've spoken to agree with
the basic General Patton presumption
which is that the idea is not to die for
your countries to make the other fellow
die for his so that would be pretty
insensitive that's one way of reading it
the other way of read
it is you know your husband was it was a
deeply brave man and he sacrificed
himself in the line of duty and that
that's what brave people do that's what
he said that's what he signed up for he
signed up because he was a brave guy
right that's that's another way of
reading out to a man Luis over at the
Daily Beast's has suggested and that is
a plausible read we don't know because
we weren't there in the conversation now
is it entirely possible that Trump said
something out of a something out of
bounds and said something nasty or
unconsciously cruel sure that's always a
possibility but we just don't know and
we have to take into account the biases
of the actors so a lot of people are
saying well Trump isn't credible on
these issues cuz Trump constantly says
he doesn't do things wrong and he's
constantly fibbing about it there's
truth to that it is also true that
fredericka Wilson is a radical left
Democrat who has been saying for months
that Donald Trump is crazy
and that he should be impeached I mean
she's literally been saying you should
be impeached for months so we're
supposed to take her word at face value
this is the same woman who suggested
that george zimmerman should have been
locked up without evidence in the
trayvon martin case
she said that he should have gone to
jail he should've been in prison and
then she said he should be put in prison
for his own safety
alright so Frederica Wilson is not
exactly the most credible source now the
follow-up on this is that the mother of
the of the widow
Myesha Johnson's mother sorry if I
pronounce this correctly I think some
Ayesha's Johnson's mother her mother
came out and said that the conversation
basically went down the same way that
that Frederick Wilson said she told the
Washington Post on Wednesday she was in
the car during the call from the White
House and quote President Trump did
disrespect my son and my daughter and
also me and my husband she said asked
whether Wilson's accounts of the
conversation between Trump and the
family was accurate she replied yes now
I would like to hear from the I'd like
to hear from the daughter from this
woman's daughter I'd like to hear from
the wife the White House apparently has
no interest in revealing the contents of
the conversation a White House official
released a statement saying the
president's conversations with the
families of American heroes who have
made the ultimate sacrifice are private
well then Trump probably shouldn't have
tweeted about how he had proof of it so
here's the point the point is that
everyone likes to jump to conclusions
based on lack of evidence if you're just
going to stack up the evidence at this
point did Trump say something rude
or not in a call to a widow the evidence
would have to be on the side of yes is
it this positive no of course it's not
just positive we just don't know at this
point because we don't have a recording
of the call we don't have text of the
call we haven't even heard from the
widow herself and heard from her mother
and we have heard from the and we have
heard from the sorry and we have also
heard from from Frederica Wilson so
those are the sources that we have heard
from at this point and that does not
necessarily mean and that does not
necessarily mean that Frederick Wilson
is a good source so we should always
take this sort of stuff with a little
bit of a grain of salt and I think that
we ought to wait for all of the evidence
to come out it also demonstrates that
President Trump really needs to stop
stepping on every landmine
not every landmine is worth stepping on
I hate these sorts of fights I mean
really this is the the third time second
third time that President Trump has
gotten into it with a gold star family I
just it's just a waste of time it's a
waste of space there's no reason to do
this it's completely fruitless just we
should have left it behind unfortunately
the culture wars are what Americans are
interested in however we have major
policy issues on the table we have
Obamacare we have tax reform we have so
many things that need to be done and yet
we are consumed with cultural issues
every day because it's easy to run to a
side it's very easy to run to a side and
declare your virtuousness or the other
guy's evil that's what's happening on a
consistent basis so President Trump
spoke and Heritage Foundation yesterday
and in speaking at Heritage Foundation
he spent an awful lot of time talking
about these cultural issues because
Trump knows better than anyone else that
he was elected on the basis of culture
not on the basis of policy right all the
talk about trumping a typical Republican
presidents on policy that's not actually
why he was elected he was not elected as
a Republican on policy he was elected
because he likes fighting culture wars
and there are a lot of people who are
angry at the prevailing state of
American culture so over at the Heritage
Foundation he dropped some Republican
conservative red-meat he started off by
saying that freedom is a gift from God
not from government the most important
truth our founders understood was this
freedom is not a gift from government
freedom is a gift from God
ok so I love that you know it's a great
line but that's not why people voted for
Trump either I'm gonna show you why
people voted for Trump in just a second
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at the u.s.
concealed-carry Association so you're in
your house it's the middle of the night
you hear somebody rattling the lock on
the front door and then you hear a
crowbar being jammed into the lock you
go to your safe you get your gun you
load it up you walk out there's somebody
breaking through the door and sure
enough you have to shoot them that's the
end of the story right well not so much
now the police are gonna come they're
going to talk to you there they may
arrest you this is why you need the 2017
concealed carry and family defense guide
from the u.s. concealed carry
Association in it you will learn how to
detect attackers before they see you how
to survive a mass shooting the safest
most dangerous places to sit in a
restaurant how to responsibly own and
store a gun particularly if you have
little kids as I do and a whole lot more
is a 164 pages and it comes with a bonus
audio version so you can listen in your
car as well it's a hundred percent free
and for a limited time you also get a
bonus home defense checklist so you can
make sure that your home is as safe as
it can possibly be go to to Fenton my
family now calm right now for 100% free
instant access
that's defend my family now calm again
defend my family now calm don't get
caught up short when you have to defend
your family defend my family now calm go
check it out so that is again a way to
keep your family safe ok so when
President Trump at Heritage Foundation
dropped a bunch of lines that were
really more campaign lines than anything
else here as president Trump saying that
he's going to bring Merry Christmas back
you're gonna be saying Merry Christmas
again ok gonna say Merry Christmas you
know
you go to the stores and they have the
red walls and they have the snow and
they even have the sleigh and the whole
thing they don't have Merry Christmas
they don't have Merry Christmas I want
them to say Merry Christmas everybody
Happy New Year Happy Holidays but I want
Merry Christmas okay so if this is a
major issue to you then this is why you
voted for Trump okay so the reason that
this works for Trump is because is it
kind of dumb yeah we were all saying
Merry Christmas anyway it's good that
the president wants to say Merry
Christmas Christmas is a national
holiday all of that is worthwhile as an
Orthodox Jew I can say that I say Merry
Christmas to Christians all the time on
Christmas the idea that you shouldn't is
ridiculous however the idea this is a
thing that Trump is going to accomplish
for us that that saying Merry Christmas
is now going to be in vogue again
because Trump is president I think it's
dumb but it is one of the reasons why
Trump won is because people feel
inundated by the culture of the left
they feel inundated by the culture of
the left on a consistent basis
constantly and I think for a good reason
and so Trump likes to focus on this
right this is the stuff that Trump oh
this is the great mystery about Trump
Trump was not elected to get Republican
policy done he was elected because we
wanted a talk-show host as presidents of
the United States who's going to talk
about these issues and shift these
issues which is why I see so many
conservatives who are so excited about
Trump talking about kneeling in the NFL
and think from won some sort of great
victory by taking down the ratings for
the NFL because the culture war matters
the culture war does matter I just think
the culture war should be won in the
culture as opposed to being won in the
political sphere maybe that's a little
bit too high-minded of me but I'm more
interested in the President of the
United States actually promulgating good
policy than I am in him telling people
they can say Merry Christmas again I
think we can do both by the way I don't
think it's irrelevant down the president
can't say this stuff but this is the if
it I would suffice to say I think for a
lot of Republican voters if Trump gets
nothing done but he says this kind of
stuff
it would rather that then they need not
say this kind of stuff but get a bunch
of things done Trump continued along
these lines he says that people are
trying to destroy Columbus statues we
believe we should preserve our history
tear it down now they're even trying to
destroy statues of Christopher Columbus
what's next
has to be stopped it's heritage okay so
again the idea that that then the
Christopher Columbus statues are coming
down i've protested that - I think it's
idiotic he's correct about this again
this is all culture war type stuff more
culture war type stuff he says the
American flag should be treated with
respect again I agree with all of these
basic principles that he is stating
right now the only point that I make me
is this seems to be a tremendous focus
for Trump for a reason and that is that
we're not getting anything done
legislatively we believe that our great
American flag should be treated with
reverence and respect and that young
Americans should be taught to love our
country honor our anthem and proudly
recite the Pledge of Allegiance okay so
again agreed with all of this but this
is the real reason why Trump won and
this is why we're going to just keep
devolved into cultural wars and not
paying attention to the news some of
that's on the media the media don't want
to pay attention to those it's more fun
to talk about culture wars some of that
is on President Trump who was elected to
talk culture wars and not really to
engage with policy so when the Trump
administration says why aren't you guys
talking about raka they're right but it
would help if President Trump didn't
feel the need to engage in a culture
where every five minutes obscuring his
other accomplishments now Democrats have
responded to all of this by suggesting
of course that it's all Republicans
fault but the reason we have these
culture wars it's all Republicans fault
so Joe Biden came out yesterday former
vice president and said the demise of
rhetoric in America began with Newt
Gingrich we saw the beginning of the
demise of the nature the discourse when
the Gingrich revolution started occur
went on the floor of the United States
Senate a senator would refer to a
sitting president as Bubba when Fred
when someone forget Democrat Republican
when someone would yell at a State of
the Union wire the destruction of these
norms and it's generating chaos really
that was the destruction of the norms
wasn't like Teddy Kennedy heading over
to the Soviet Union in 1980
four and talking with the Soviet Union
about how he could help them undermine
Ronald Reagan
it wasn't like Jimmy Carter in 1980
talking pretty openly about how much he
despised Ronald Reagan like that's when
the order went away it wasn't like the
1960s when people were rioting in the
streets that it really began with Newt
Gingrich really and Joe Biden doesn't
really have a leg to stand on here when
it comes to the civility and rhetoric
routine here is Joe Biden circa 2012
talking about putting y'all back in
Chains look at what they value and look
at their budget and what they're
proposing Romney wants to let that he
said in the first hundred days he's got
the big banks once again write their own
rules unchain Wall Street they're gonna
put y'all back in Chains I'm gonna black
audience when he said that but Joe Biden
gets to stand around talking about how
he is just the halcyon of civility and
then you wonder why Republicans are so
mad that they want to engage in this in
this culture war because Democrats also
want to engage in the culture war so
instead of having useful policy
discussions we'll engage in culture wars
and nothing will get done speaking of
nothing getting done health care policy
is stalled out again so one of the big
questions is whether President Trump is
gonna cut subsidies to all of the
Obamacare exchanges he should ok
Congress has not approved any of the
subsidies for the Obamacare exchanges
and for the insurance companies you
should use that as a lever to make
Congress change the law and free up
those insurance companies to open up the
insurance market right then you won't
need the subsidies if you actually free
it free them up to sell plans at the
prices that they ought to be sold but
that only died today the last 48 hours
were basically a whirlwind of stupidity
first Lamar Alexander and and patty
Murray came up with a bargain that Chuck
Schumer liked where they would continue
to fund the Obamacare subsidies here's
what here's Chuck Schumer praising man
um I want to salute both Lamar Alexander
and patty Murray for working hard on a
bipartisan solution we think it's a good
solution and it got broad support when
patty and I talked about it at the
caucus at lunch today
first it stabilizes the system two year
in two years of cost-sharing provides
real stability to the system and we want
to make sure that happens we want to
work in the long term to reduce premiums
and increase coverage our Republican
colleagues seem to be in the opposite
place on the long term but I think
there's a growing consensus that in the
short term we need stability in the
markets so we've achieved stability if
this agreement becomes law we've also
put in some very significant anti
sabotage provisions the President had
been sabotaging this bill and the
agreement would undo much of that
sabotage okay so he's super happy about
this and then Trump goes out and he says
that he likes the Alexander Murray deal
too he says that they're gonna buy buy
it for a couple of years right here's
him yesterday Lamar has been working
very very hard with the Democratic his
colleagues on the other side and patty
Murray is one of them
in particular and they're coming up and
they're fairly close to a short term
solution the solution will be for about
a year or two years and it'll get us
over this intermediate hump because we
have as you probably know we have either
have the vote so we're very close to
having Trump was ready to go the Senate
was ready to go the person who stopped
it was that Paul Ryan Paul Ryan
said we're not going to pass this
through the house as well he should so
that thing lives and dies inside of 48
hours but we're not talking policy right
we're two-thirds of the way through the
show I'm not talking policy because the
culture wars are more important than
policy in the minds of most Americans
well I want to stop and say thank you to
our sponsors over at stamps.com so you
don't need to wait in line at the post
office okay I actually don't mind the
post office but waiting in line bothers
makes I'm there for an hour waiting to
get some stamps or waste and postage you
don't have to do that anymore stamps
calm brings all the service of the US
Postal Service right to your fingertips
you can buy and print official US
postage for any letter any package any
with mail using your own computer and
printer stamps com just makes it that
easy they'll send you a digital scale it
automatically calculates exact postage
and they'll even help you decide the
best class of mail based on your needs
you don't have to lease an expensive
postage meter so right now you can get
stamps calm with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage
and the digital scales that's pretty
valuable offer without any long-term
commitments go to stamps.com click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Shapiro remember
you have to do that in order to get that
special deal the four week trial plus
postage and digital scale revolutionize
how your business does mailing stamps
comm type in Shapiro in the microphone
at the top of the page and that will
allow you to get the offer again the
stamps comm promo code Shapiro stamps
comm you never have to go to the post
office again okay so I'm very eager to
get to things I like in things I hate
today because I have some special things
I like and things that I hate that I
want to talk about so let's start with
some things that I like so we begin
today someone tweeted at me what is the
thing the the most popular opinion you
hold an opinion that lots of other
people hold that you are most
embarrassed of this opinion is that
Chris Farley is hilarious I for some
reason think Chris Farley is just the
funniest thing that ever was and his
death is a tragedy that is one of the
this movie that I'm about to that I'm
about to praise when I showed this to my
parents they looked at me like I was a
crazy person
my my sister's also think this movie is
really funny my dad thinks I'm a
for liking this movie the movie of
course is Tommy Boy with David Spade and
Chris Farley I cannot stop laughing at
this movie I think it is just
hysterically funny and I think Chris
Farley and David Spade play off each
other beautifully here of course is the
preview for that great comedic classic
Tommy Boy
[Music]
holy schnikeys except for me no son
that's for me
[Music]
you know a lot of people go to college
for seven years I know they're called
doctors this always has been always will
be a family firm ah son of one someday
my son will run I am your father
[Music]
I've interrupted happy time oh do we
really want to put the future of the
company in Tommy's hands
[Music]
promise me you'll look after tommy-boy
until he gets his feet wet sure and
thanks for choosing me tell me this is
not a vacation for me I'm not here
against my will the least you can do is
pretend to work I can actually hear you
getting fatter alright it's sale time -
remember we don't take no for an answer
[Music]
preview does not do justice to the
hilarity of this film there there are a
couple scenes that are really great
there's one scene in particular where
he's doing a sales job and explaining
and using the metaphor of a car crash
it's pretty spectacular so if you are in
the mood for dumb humor much better than
dumb and dumber go go get Tommy Boy okay
other things that I like I could not
resist this so this was a series of
tweets that came out that came out
yesterday which is just hysterical
showing how dumb white supremacists are
so we have to we have to show the series
of tweets there they're really
spectacular do we have those so Ivan
thrown at dark triad many said this is
called art this is the legacy and
heritage of the West this is what the
men of the West fight sacrifice and die
for this is victory
hashtag Dave's volt okay it's a statue
if you can't see it it's a statue of a
very smoking-hot woman hair blowing in
the wind and a dress blowing backwards
clinging to her body and this is what we
fight for okay and the next thing that
happens is that somebody tweets is there
an example of a female sculptor who
committed herself to the same level of
detail that a male does with a woman and
I've been throwing tweets back none that
come to mind that sculptor that
sculpture is an act of worship before
heaven and it shows and then they're
informed by Pliny the Elder quote the
sculptor is a Chinese woman u-dor cast
losers and here's a picture of the
sculpture and the sculptor so it was a
Chinese woman who made that tribute to
the West again showing that culture is
significantly more important culture and
art significantly more important than
the color of your skin or the place of
your birth so all of the more on white
supremacist who think that great art can
only be created by white men no no I
just I loved that I thought it was so
great I
could not resist showing that to you
okay so we're gonna break here on the
other side yeah I still have some epic
things I hate including Sarah Silverman
we're going to talk about that plus I
need a hill lots of stuff still to talk
about but for that I'm gonna have to go
over to Daley wired.com and subscribe
for $9.99 a month you can subscribe over
at Daley wire.com that means you get my
show live on video it means you get clay
the show live on video and nolza show
live on video it means you get to be
part of our mailbags
you get to be part of conversations when
we do our special our special Q&A
sessions clayvin did his yesterday which
went great
you can ask the questions when you join
up as a member and for $99 a year you
can get the annual subscription
including our fabulous leftist here's
hot or called tumblr world-famous you
will enjoy it it is the greatest of all
beverage vessels so go and check that
out
or if you just want to listen for free
later please subscribe over at YouTube
and make sure you listen at iTunes or
SoundCloud as well and leave us a review
we always appreciate it we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
you
okay time for some things that I hate so
let's do that okay so we begin with we
begin with Siena so this hashtag meets
who has been going around I talked about
it yesterday and what I was suggesting
is that I'm not against women telling
their stories of sexual harassment or
sexual assault I think it's important
that they do so but I think it's
significantly more useful if you are
going to come out and give me evidence
right because it's hard for me to side
with you without evidence of even who
you're accusing because there are cases
we know public cases right UVA Lena
Dunham
on racial matters Bennett Michael
Bennett is the Seattle Seahawks
defensive end right there there's
there's all sorts of cases where people
make accusations that turn out not to be
true and this idea that we owe them our
credibility at the beginning that we are
credulous Ness at the very beginning I
don't think is right I don't think
that's correct I think that we owe
people the respect of hearing their
stories but the problem with vague
stories that don't actually name names
is that it's difficult for us to
determine who the bad guys are and how
to fight the bad guys I mean beyond
that's a horrible thing that you just
told me about I'm not sure what we're
supposed to do about that I have no
intention of engaging in similar
activity so what would you like from me
and that's always the question right the
question is what can we do from here I
mean when we're talking about these the
Harvey Weinstein scandal when we're
talking about we're talking about
there's a this some what's the name of
the gymnast there's this famous gymnast
who just came out a little while ago
okay in mckayla maroney
sorry who just came out and and said the
doctor on the u.s. women's team had
molested her for years right that's you
know that's a case where we can see the
person who did it and we can say that
person belongs in jail this is why I
suggested that stars need to come out
and they need to name names because they
can afford the legal fees if somebody
Sue's them for slander they can go to
court if you're an up-and-comer you
don't have any money there there's
sexual harassment there's sexual
harassment statutes of limitations then
it's a year in many states where you
have time to actually file a sexual
harassment claim if you're beyond that
then you could get sued presumably for
slander at least that's what I've been
told by a reporter over at The Wall
Street Journal
you know that I understand all those
concerns
but if you want us to fight individual
bad guys we have to know who the
individual bad guys are and this is Lord
of so it's sort of like saying fight
Nazism you're like well I don't like
Nazis Nazis are evil and not sin Nazism
is bad and they say well you're not
fighting hard enough and like well what
do you want me to do you actually have
to like show me a Nazi and then we can
determine the best way to fight that
Nazi so here's the reason that this is a
problem so CNN ran a story today in
which they they had on anita hill to
talk about Harvey Weinstein this is a
Bugaboo of mine it drives me up a wall
when the media HBO just did a miniseries
about Anita Hill do this whole routine
like Anita Hill unquestionably was
telling the truth Anita Hill was clearly
telling the truth about being sexually
harassed by Clarence Thomas there are a
number of facts that call into question
her account of exactly what happened
with Clarence Thomas ok the fact is that
Anita Hill was was I mean she was not
found credible by a huge percentage of
the American population for a variety of
reasons including the fact that she
insisted on speaking to the Senate
Judiciary Committee in confidence not
publicly right and not with her name
attached well if she made a specific
accusation wouldn't Thomas know who she
was anyway so that really means that she
was making accusations that were so
vague they presumably could have come
from anybody right this is what Thomas
Sol says he says think about it the
accusations refer to things that were
supposed to have happened when only two
people were present if the accusations
were true Clarence Thomas would
automatically know who originated them
Anita's Hill Anita Hills request friend
and nobody made sense only if the
charges were false Hill admitted under
oath that although she previously denied
being told something by a Democratic
staffer she actually was there's a dozen
women who came out in support of
Clarence Thomas contradicting I need a
hill hill made numerous phone calls to
to Clarence Thomas long after she
stopped working for him she followed him
from job to job even though she worked
for the federal government where there's
tremendous job security a witness who
said that she was told details about the
supposed sexual harassment while the two
were living in Washington didn't even
live in Washington at the time so that
there are serious credibility problems
they needed help nonetheless here is CNN
today quote Anita Hill on Harvey
Weinstein we have to ask how far have we
come to equality and they're using Anita
Hill as sort of the talking point says
the Harvey Weinstein scandal suggests
workplace conditions have not improved
near
enough for women in the 26 years since
then Supreme Court nominee Clarence
Thomas was accused of workplace sexual
harassment his accuser Anita Hill told
CNN's new day on Wednesday it's a number
one Anita Hills credibility has been in
question for years number two it's kind
of weird don't you think that Sienna
never runs a story saying the Harvey
Weinstein scandal suggests workplace
conditions have not improved nearly
enough for women since Kathleen Willey
accused the President of the United
States of groping her in the Oval Office
I never hear from Kathleen Willey
you never hear from Onita Broderick you
never hear from Paula Jones you never
heard from a variety of women a variety
of women who were sexually harassed or
assaulted by President Clinton all you
hear about is the one who claims that
she was by Clarence Thomas but was never
proved it in court and never even filed
a case so there's that okay other things
that I hate so Sarah Silverman has a new
series it's called I love you a marathon
now Sarah Silverman bugs me for a
variety of reasons I'm not a fan of the
cutesy use of the c-word you know she
doesn't like a little child's voice and
then she curses like a sailor I don't
find that particularly amusing she's
also a hardcore leftist who really looks
down on on red-state America and
Republicans in any area of American life
I mean she campaigned for Bernie Sanders
so of course she's the perfect person
that Hollywood and Netflix are gonna
trot out to - I think it's who who
actually he's gonna try it out to unite
Americans like Sarah so I can't think of
a more unifying figure than Sarah
Silverman so here's Sarah Silverman's
trailer for I Love You America
[Music]
you
you know Korean or Irish and lovely
North Carolina
[Music]
we don't matter what I'm doing I'm
listing kinds of people
I'm categorizing human beings and
putting them into little individual
boxes I mean whether I mean it or not
I'm part of the problem
okay I mean you can see this is not
funny at all but beyond that the idea
that she's the great unifier was belied
by the first episode of this awful show
she went to Louisiana and she basically
found a family of fat people to talk to
and to mock and she tried to make it
seem like oh and then at the end of the
day we decided we loved each other
so a couple of things about this
particular family this particular
family's Pro same-sex marriage this is
the litmus test in Hollywood if your
anti-same-sex marriage you are Satan you
are Satan so this family was convenient
they happen to be Pro same-sex marriage
or at least okay with it
that is the litmus test in Hollywood but
they did vote for Donald Trump and you
can see I mean the whole show is
designed it's supposed to be about how
much he loves people the whole show is
designed to show how she's basically
like Steve Irwin in the wild
interviewing a crocodile so here's a
clip from it you ever met a Jew before
what Jewish person ah okay that's a good
question it's like a religion but I'm
not I don't really follow it I am a Jew
before did they have the law it's the
only thing I know the Jews with a little
hat yarmulke
yeah yeah I'm going to buy the buy Eve
buyer what do I sound like to you well
you know
I didn't know Jewish people growing up
because I'm from New Hampshire but then
I moved to New York and I was like oh my
god they got a lot easy and never met a
Jew before yeah except for like okay so
if you never manager you never minded
you a big deal I'm significantly more
Jewish than Sarah Silverman like a lot
more Jewish than her school in terms of
my practice and believe me I've dealt
with many more people from Louisiana
than Sarah Silverman ever has I'm in
Tennessee today right I can't go all
around the country I talk to people all
across the spectrum all around the
country and the idea that you know that
everyone who doesn't live in her social
milieu is kind of a hick and then but
we're all the same underneath well know
we have some pretty different values and
I think that what Sarah Silverman needs
to learn is not that we're all humans
underneath if you don't get that by now
you're dumb what you really need to
learn is that if you have different
political viewpoints with somebody if
you have different religious viewpoints
from somebody like that's significantly
differ that maybe that's okay and I
don't think that Sarah Silverman needs
to go out to Louisiana and find people
with no teeth in order to do that right
I think that she needs to go into
Hollywood and talk to the Conservatives
that she won't deal with that her
ex-husband Jimmy Kimmel says he doesn't
want have a conversation with and maybe
have a conversation with them and maybe
did you have a discussion like maybe
she's wrong about some things has that
ever occurred to her or is this
basically just gonna be I do me and you
do you and we all love each other and
what do we have in common that we're
human and that is the most boring unity
crap it's so boring if we don't have a
common vision for the country if we
don't have any values in common then
yeah we're still human and we have that
in common I suppose but it doesn't
really go very far and that's sort of
why the show is bound to fail plus it
looks absolutely boring and terrible
okay so I was gonna do a little bit of
Bible talk but I think that we have run
out of time so I may save that for
tomorrow I'm speaking at University of
Tennessee in Knoxville tonight my speech
is going to be somewhat different than
the speeches that I normally get so I am
looking forward to trotting out
something new ooh interesting
fascinating or boring who knows it could
be terrible in any case I will see you
here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]